hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
here at google cloud
in this video i want to introduce you to
migrate4anthos
migrate4anthos is a set of tools that
inspects existing workloads running in
virtual machines
and automatically creates the needed
container artifacts for modernization
let me break down that last sentence
into two parts and talk separately about
where these virtual machines might be
running and what types of artifacts
migrate for anthos creates migrate for
anthos can migrate both windows and
linux applications
windows applications can be running on a
google compute engine vm
in addition to google compute engine
linux applications can also be hosted
on-prem
with vmware vsphere aws cc2 and azure
vms
in migrate for anthos where your vm
currently resides is called the
migration source
for this video the source will be an
application running in a vm
on compute engine the output from
migrate for anthos is a comprehensive
set of
artifacts that you can use to deploy
your newly containerized application
these artifacts include a kubernetes
yaml file that you can use to create
kubernetes deployments and services
a docker file that can be used to create
a new container image
and other yaml files that describe what
was actually
migrated once you have these artifacts
you can deploy the containerized version
of your application to an anthoc cluster
or to the various flavors of google
kubernetes engine including gke running
on google cloud
on prem or on aws so you have an
application running on a supported
source
and you can use migrate francis to get
it running in a container
but why would you do that there are
several key benefits to migrating your
workloads
the first is density containers are much
lighter weight than vms since they don't
contain the operating system and
therefore require considerably fewer
compute
and memory resources this in turn allows
greater density of workloads across your
clusters
fine grain resource allocations and
overall lower infrastructure costs
another benefit is security gke offers
automatic operating system upgrades
freeing you from the burden of
maintaining your operating system
you can also augment legacy apps with
modern services
gke allows you to leverage platform
add-on services
to seamlessly integrate up-to-date
functionality with existing apps
for instance you can take advantage of
istio on gke
or asm on amthos to automate network and
security policies without changing your
application code
additionally you can leverage cloud
logging and cloud monitoring with your
applications
unified policy and integrated resource
management
gka allows you to focus on managing
applications not
infrastructure it offers the power of
declarative desired state management
with powerful tagging strategies and
selector policies
you can also move to modern image based
management and orchestration
migrate for anthos offers a unique
capability to extract an application
from the vm workload
and construct a docker image and related
artifacts which in turn
allows you to modernize the application
lifecycle and operations management
this could include integrating with a ci
cd pipeline
using tools like cloud build to
implement day two maintenance procedures
furthermore image based management
enables customers to use gke to perform
rolling updates dynamic scaling
self-healing
and more so now you have a general idea
of what migrate for anthos does and
why you might choose to use it let's
jump into an actual migration
migrate for anthos has three primary
components
the discovery tool which assesses how
successful a migration of a given
application might be
the processing cluster a kubernetes
cluster that is used to examine the
source vm
and create the migration plan as well as
execute the actual migration
and mig ctl a command line tool like
coupe ctl
for interacting with the processing
cluster mix ctl is already installed in
cloud shell
a migration generally consists of the
following steps and don't worry if
you're not sure of what each of these
steps
actually means we're going to get into
that as we move through this video
series
first you need to create a google
project set up service accounts and
enable appropriate apis
next you create a migration processing
cluster then you go into the process of
choosing and qualifying your targeted
workload
once you've done that you can define
your migration source using mixctl to
create a migration plan
then you adjust that migration plan to
ensure that it meets your needs
then you create the deployment artifacts
and then you can deploy your newly
containerized application
in the rest of this video i'm going to
talk about the first two steps since
they are largely the same
whether you are deploying linux or
windows applications
i will cover the remaining steps in
subsequent videos
now that we have the migration process
laid out let's jump into setting up the
prerequisites for a migration
migrate for anthos requires two service
accounts the first service account is
used by migrate for anthos to access
container registry and cloud storage
you will use this service account when
you install the migratefranthos
components
and it requires storage admin
permissions the second service account
enables compute engine as a migration
source and it requires
computer viewer and computer storage
admin roles i will actually create this
service account in a follow-on video
but i wanted to make sure you were aware
of it in addition to the two service
accounts you will enable the following
apis that are shown on the screen
the next prerequisite we need to deal
with is the processing cluster
as mentioned before a processing cluster
is a gke cluster running the actual code
that analyzes the source vm and creates
the deployment artifacts
so i will create a onenote cluster here
on the console the cluster itself is a
pretty
standard cluster we're going to name it
processing cluster we're going to put it
in us west
2 which is the same location as my vm
that i'm going to migrate
under the default pool we're going to
change that to one node we only need a
single node
and then for the actual nodes just a
couple of things
uh ubuntu image type and the n1
standard for machine type so with those
configurations
we're ready to click create and that
will go off and that will build our
cluster now this is going to take a
couple minutes
so we'll fast forward the video and
we'll check back in when that's finished
okay it looks like the processing
cluster is ready to go so the next step
is to
actually install the migrate for anthos
components
so we'll come up here we'll click into
anthos migrate to containers
and we'll come up here and we're going
to add a processing cluster so click add
processing cluster
and we're going to come down linux
workloads and we're going to select that
processing cluster we just created
click next and then we're going to run a
series of commands in cloud shell and
the first one is going to be
to enable the api as i mentioned before
so we'll copy that
paste that in and those apis will get
enabled
the next step is to go ahead and create
the service account that's going to
allow us access to the container
registry
and the storage cloud storage so we'll
paste that in
and create that service account then
we're going to go in and we're going to
assign the storage admin role
to that service account so we'll paste
this command in that'll create this
the role binding then we're going to go
in and we're going to download the json
key
so that we have that to authenticate to
the necessary services as we go forward
and then finally let's clear the screen
it's getting a little crowded
um i'm going to go ahead and i'm going
to start the installation process
of actually uh creating the migrate for
anthos components on the cluster so the
using mig ctl i do a mig ctl setup
install
and it goes through and it adds all the
necessary components to perform the
actual migration this will take just a
couple seconds
to finish up all right so now i can run
mig ctl doctor
and that'll tell me the status of my
installation
okay let's check again here with mig ctl
and mig ctl is reporting back that the
deployment has completed successfully
and we're now ready to perform an actual
migration which we're going to do in our
next
two videos we're going to have one on
migrating linux applications and the
other on migrating windows applications
to recap in this video you learn the
benefits and features of
migrateforanthos as well as how to
configure the prerequisites
be sure to like and subscribe because
we'll be posting subsequent videos in
this series including how to migrate
linux and windows applications
as well as best practices for evaluating
your applications and what
considerations you need to be aware of
when planning a migration and to get
started on migrate for anthos today
visit cloud.google.com
migrate anthos
[Music]
you